hill was brutally killed on monday
evening as peter sutcliffe carried on
killing the collection of clues became
vast
and there were no computers to manage it
all
everything was written and stored on
index cards
the paperwork simply overwhelmed
detectives
the floor of the incident room at
milgarth police station
had to be reinforced to cope you are the
pro
former you had to fill in everything you
had specific questions you asked to ask
you had to have what shoe size they had
did they have the gap in the teeth you
would do that then that would be then
forwarded
you take that back to the incident room
that would be then forward onto milga
where the mounted paper mounting just
grew and grew and grew
now you've got you know computer
technology that does all this
police interviewed sutcliffe nine times
all written up and recorded
his car was spotted sixty times and
logged
but no one made the connection so he
carried on killing i say you are still
having no look
in me i have the greatest respect for
you george
a hoaxer known as weirside jack led
police on a wild goose chase for 18
months
in that time sutcliffe killed three more
women
so what you do now is they have murder
review teams who come in
literally as your critical friend every
couple of weeks
and would question your your rationale
your decision making
police were also criticized for the
different way in which they treated the
rippers victims
separating the sex workers from what
they regarded
as more innocent victims i would say
that if you're a prostitute you probably
got a lesser investigation
to find out who'd done it before and in
fact i've worked on
uh serial killings of prostitutes but
there's a different approach now
that every case is treated as important
prostitutes are now viewed and treated
with far greater care
better police procedures perhaps the
only
positive legacy of such a dark episode
in british criminal history martin brunt
sky
news